[Music]
there is a scene or there's actually a
part of the movie where you interact
with the corpse of General Zod oh right
yeah who was played previously by
Michael Shannon and I didn't realize I
thought maybe they got Michael Shannon
this amazing actor to just sit still for
this large chunk of the movie where you
are you know hauling his corpse around
and interacting with his corpse which
son let's forget I said that
was that but it couldn't have been you
don't get an actor to just sit still
like that well you're probably not that
guy yeah no not that guy but wait you do
I wasn't directing with this corpse but
it wasn't naked it was Nate he was naked
the whole movie and more than I was
trying to get us away from that I that's
why I took us down a row yeah yeah and
use you stopped us and you brought us
back to the room and now you're with a
nude corpse what's going on with that
it's important to mention not only was
it nude but the the genitals and they
were not his genitals I was told were
really what are you talking about this
was a dummy
you're talkin bout it's a dummy it's a
it's like a wax dummy yes but this movie
was like crafted by the greatest
artisans so every hair on his body was
like an accurate accurately placed hair
so you're saying they exactly reproduce
Michael Shannon the actor and that you
saw his reproduce genitals no no no no
they reproduced this actor in his
entirety in its entirety and somebody
else's genitals because okay I guess he
didn't sign off on that final page
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because I was gonna say tiny tiny likes
it in the Arctic
you